do you know the number one rule in
rocket League well it's rule number one
turbo pulse attempts squishy and
terrible number one there in the corner
we'll see how long they maintain this
one rule number one is an Unwritten rule
of Rocket League that says if you crash
into an opponent you two stay there
until someone scores the timer hits zero
or in some cases until a teammate frees
you from this headlock by ramming into
you and this rule is as old as the game
itself at this point they were already
down two nothing UNLV off by rule one is
commenced on the backboard rule number
one is usually respected in casual and
pro play and breaking contact First is
seen as extremely shameful yeah break in
rule number one in front of an audience
that's who hell your teammates can
choose to score on their own net as a
show of penance unless Karma gets you
first just take a little fight Midfield
now what some would argue is rule number
one and now the follow-up scrub killer